are you stuck trying to grow on youtube
are you struggling to figure out how do
i make all this work and how do i
actually make money
well if you answered yes to either of
those questions then i am
so excited for you to listen to today's
episode
now here at think media we just finished
a free seven day youtube influence
challenge and during that challenge we
had tens of thousands of creators
just like you listening in on these
sessions and the session we're bringing
you today
was one of the most talked about
sessions throughout the entire
seven days and in this session sean is
going to be breaking down
how to find the right niche for you his
3p
plan for success on youtube and if the
content you're raking right now
is the right content for you i am so
fired up for you to listen to
this session now it's the time to lean
in time to take notes because i cannot
wait for you to have success
on youtube after this session
welcome to the think marketing podcast
the number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
i'm heather torres and i'm sean cannell
and we're from think media and if this
is your first time listening
welcome this show is dedicated to
helping you learn how to get your
content noticed
and the latest money making strategies
working right now
online so whether you want to grow your
youtube channel
or you want to maximize video across all
of social media this podcast
is for you get ready because we are
diving straight into
the content right now and uh
what we're going to be talking about is
session number two
and this session is um all about the
best way to make
money and make a difference with your
youtube channel but when we start this
off
you know we first have to bust a couple
youtube
myths and you know in this challenge
there's
probably a few things we need to talk
about in terms of well yo
sean it's 2020 man has the youtube ship
sailed you know youtube's 15 years old
you go i got a 15 year old in my house
and she's crazy he's acting crazy i
don't know if i can
he's 15 man you know 15 years old
is it too late to start youtube is it
still possible to break through on
youtube and that's
that's one of the big elephants in the
room youtube kind of culture in general
it's like is it too
late like is it too crowded so i looked
up a couple examples
and this is janelle elena right and you
may have heard her story you know she
joined youtube at the end of
2018 she has 22 total videos posted
and she's at 2.3 million subscribers she
didn't start in 20
2005. she didn't start in 2010 she
didn't start in 2015.
she started less than two years ago and
her channel
absolutely exploded on kind of some
entertainment vlog type
stuff right so are people still starting
from scratch and growing yes but it's
not just like
crazy examples like that right you're
like okay well she's kind of a unicorn
all right
well maybe you've heard of joanne sedia
right she's
got one million subscribers in three
months similar again kind of being
quirky kind of being herself
at the time when she really started her
channel she was 18 years old canadian
youtuber
who films all of her videos my friends
with her phone
right and really kind of her niche and
style of stuff was just being different
she's being herself
she's been a little bit weird being
opposite kind of like
covering mean stuff and she was
definitely doing some smart influence
and trend surfing which is what we'll
talk about more in the future
like she did like she diy'd emma
chamberlain's clothing line and some
other topics but she's got 3.2 million
subscribers now
and again she started just recently and
grew very fast
you remember from the first session
maybe dr eye health now this is one of
our
video ranking academy students like
started from scratch
no camera experience no editing
experience and really
he's been on youtube for less than two
years in one year's time he had 100 000
subscribers now he's at 150 000
subscribers
14 000 new people are subscribing to his
channel a month
and he posts five videos a month about
one
a week i think one of the powerful
things i like about dr eye health is
it's really clear
what his channel channel's all about
right it's powerful to have that niche
and we're going to talk about that in
this session
this is plants and lucia i remember when
she joined video ranking academy she had
nothing like zero
subscribers i remember when she had 168
subscribers
now she's at 6 400 and she's getting
51 000 subscribers a month
right she only posts she posts about two
videos a week
and she's growing by 1300 new
subscribers a week
and she started listen february 2019.
so she started basically a year
and two months ago like obviously i'm
not sharing anybody that started a month
ago because this stuff doesn't happen
overnight but
in just a year like imagine if you're
starting from scratch
you're getting 1 390 new subscribers a
month
right imagine you start like you're
getting
51 000 views a month
and so what's cool is we showed like
janelle elena and sometimes i might be
like well man i don't think that's
impossible
this is more practical than you could
ever imagine
is it too late to start youtube my
friends absolutely not
and notice these are people from
different backgrounds they live in
different places in the world
different styles of channels maybe
you've heard of roger wakefield we had
him on the think marketing podcast and
he's one of the speakers at our event
called grow with video live happening
later this year
the expert plumber 4 100 new subs a
month he's at 37
000 subscribers 345 000 views a month
what's crazy right
is as an entrepreneur as a businessman
he's got a plumbing business
in dallas his plumbing business was
doing great
but he had a marketing company he's
paying them thousands a month well they
weren't even really getting
results as a lot of marketing companies
really do they just like pretend like
they're doing stuff to your website
and they kind of will spend your money
on ads and then like pretend they get
you leads
and you're always like are they even
working but as a business owner he's
like you know what
i'm gonna just fire my marketing company
i'm gonna go all in on youtube he hired
his son to help film the videos
and to post the videos online and
whatnot and to apply our trainings to
the videos right
and now his channel has just been
exploding it's just been growing
and not only has he had more business
than he can handle but he's building
entirely new income streams
right and so this is the power of and he
started very recently
he actually set up his channel a while
ago put a bunch of the wrong videos on
youtube
he had the wrong videos he wasn't
consistent but when he pivoted his
strategy and he started to do youtube
right
and when he started to post the right
videos everything changed you know
nicole kids ot help
uh she is a kid's occupational therapist
and she has um really been on youtube
for about two years you know the last
like focused but now she's at 70
000 subscribers she gets almost 300 000
views a month and 4
600 new moms are subscribing to her
channel
every single month crazy right
and all these different niches and maybe
you've heard of
donia angelo right the grandma that went
viral right
she lives on a ranch in mexico and there
her channel name in spanish i believe it
says
from my ranch to your kitchen she has
2.6
million subs she started youtube
recently right
and she posts eight videos a month so
two a week
15 million views a month 15 million
my friends and 110 000 new subscribers a
month
and the videos like are shot on a phone
and they're jump cut there's no intro
there's no special music there's no
special logo there's no special anything
right
but this sweet amazing grandma shares
her
recipes her cooking and her channel has
just
exploded so whether it's 2.6 million
subscribers
or whether it's 6 000 subscribers i
think the theme that we can see clearly
here
is that it's not too late to start and
youtube is a marathon and not a sprint
but that's some pretty rapid success dr
eye health
from zero to a hundred thousand in a
year is crazy lucia from about
zero to six thousand in a year and
monetizing by the way
in a lot of creative ways is also crazy
so
there's so many different paths of
course different niches and different
positioning influences it but that's
what this session is all about because
we got to get clear
on what is your most profitable
profitable path and best
niche for you to be in on youtube but
there's a few other myths
to bust really quick that i see a lot
and one of them again
is that youtube is too crowded well we
learned in the first session
that there's actually two billion
monthly active users on youtube that's
billion with the b
that's a lot of people my friends right
like so there's a lot of creators
there's also a lot of viewers and guess
what viewership is going up especially
more
so with the lockdown but i read an
article in the huffington post that also
talked about
the surge of consumers that are coming
online
in the next couple years and there's
actually three to five billion
new people coming online right now
because more people are getting on
smartphones
internet's going more places around the
world internet's becoming more
commonplace speeds of the internet speed
is going up
so not only is there tons of people but
there's more people coming online so is
youtube crowded
yes but also there's more and more and
more
viewers so really that's a myth that's
been busted
people say money like i just don't have
the money to start
youtube well we saw from these examples
like youtube
which is free plus your smartphone is
all you need to get started
i get it like we'll help you find other
tech some niches
yeah maybe you want a fancy live stream
setup or whatever that's fine
but um youtube plus your smartphone is
we've seen tons of examples right of
people that use
just those tools to get going um talent
people say like you know well i just
don't know
like i'm not tom cruise man you know i'm
not angelina jolie
like but youtube is not hollywood that's
what i love about youtube because
sure you have to build skills that's why
you're in this challenge but it's really
not the same skills like
you're not limited it's not the nba it's
not hollywood
if you bring authenticity and value and
circle that word
authenticity like when you're yourself
you know i don't think anybody would
have looked at
dania angelo and thought oh yeah she's
like she's gonna be a hollywood actress
but she's got two million subscribers on
youtube
so age is irrelevant where you live is
irrelevant ethnicity is irrelevant
like when you bring yeah strategies when
you level up your skills
but when you're authentic and here's the
key when you deliver value to a target
audience
people connect with you youtube's
different than any other place
time i don't have enough time to do this
it only takes a few hours a week and
stay locked into every single session
because heather
taurus is the absolute
most incredible productivity time
management
um and really life juggling expert
with kids as a homeschool family
the chief operation officer of think
media as a content creator as a
podcaster
you know as a friend to so many people
as someone who helps in church and
and does so many different things she is
able to pull all that off
because look it's really that not that
you don't have enough time
it's that you probably haven't really
set priorities and got
a hold of your time you know got you
started managing your time and she's
going to break down some simple
strategies so you could be like man i'm
learning a lot but how am i going to get
all this done how they're just going to
break that down so don't miss
a session of the challenge well i don't
have enough connections yo i don't know
i don't know anybody i don't know if i i
don't know george lucas
can't shout me out to get me my my movie
deal i don't know
dr dre to get me my record deal no no
youtube
is about content not connections this
kid right here remember college dropout
small town kid
started shooting videos in my bedroom no
connections in hollywood
you just you got to put in the hustle
yeah you got to put in the work
but it's about the content not the
connections content is king and content
rises to the top
and maybe you've thought this one before
oh someone took my idea already
i already saw a youtube channel somebody
already has my idea there
have you ever thought that tell me in
the comments right man someone's doing
exactly what i want to do
they took my video idea they're actually
doing the video i was about
to do well chances are there's somebody
who's literally already made the videos
you want to make
remember in session number one the what
you do
they didn't even do it the how you'll do
it but remember it's also about the
why you did it you're gonna do it
differently but here's the power
when someone is taking your ideas if
they're getting views and subscribers
and they have influence on youtube
it actually proves they're a market it
proves that there is a market
this is a misunderstood concept by a lot
of people if actually
nobody is doing what you want to do on
youtube it actually might be a sign that
that's a bad niche to go in
it could be either a really good idea or
it actually just means that
not really anybody is interested in it
like
let's remember in session one we talked
about starbucks like
what they do is they make coffee was
nobody else making coffee at the time
are you kidding me where i grew up in
seattle up in marysville washington
there was espresso stands on every
corner starbucks was selling coffee
dunkin donuts was selling coffee and
there was hipster coffee shops literally
everywhere
everybody was selling coffee someone
took the coffee idea
is it crowded yes the coffee market was
crowded
but they came in with their unique style
and their how and their why was
different
and their execution of strategy was
different
and and well executed and so the good
thing
is there's a market of people that want
to drink coffee look there's a market
if you're in the right niche and that's
what we're talking about right a proven
market something that people
are interested in so
tell me if you've believed any of these
myths or if you've heard any of them
because i'd also love to answer them
with heather as we talk about q a
on but have you seen any of these myths
what are some of the people
saying or even some of your own mindsets
that maybe family members or friends say
to you as it pertains to youtube or you
think about yourself
that you count yourself out look if you
don't get your mind right
you're gonna shoot down your success
before you even start like you're gonna
talk yourself out of it
like this is why confidence is so
important if you don't have confidence
you're always going to find a way to
lose
yeah like you've got to get into a
confident state to be like okay
youtube's legit these myths are false
and it's not too late to start and i'm
going to commit
and i'm going all in because it is going
to take work you don't get
wholehearted results with half-hearted
hearted efforts
if you're dabbling you're not going to
get the results of the people that are
dominating so can we agree these myths
are busted
which kind of now brings us to the
question they're like how do i find my
niche now maybe you've already found
yours
or maybe you uh have no clue what your
thing is yet
and if you do know your niche shout me
out in the comments below but this
session might mess you up a little bit
because it might get you you know just
some clarity or some thoughts in terms
of
uh pivoting or going into a different
direction or a different niche
i need my pen for this one and here's
what we're going to do how do you find
your niche now we have
in our training program video ranking
academy a few different processes that
we take
people through this is one of them okay
so what i want you to do is get out your
journal get out
something to write with and to lean in
for this
exercise and if you haven't started
taking notes yet you know
i encourage you to because you need a
battle plan right this is your strategy
but it's like your back black book
of strategy right so get ready to to jot
some things down
and what i want you to do is just draw a
circle before you do
you could draw it right right up here
right up here okay
and inside of that circle i want you
to write the word passion
passion okay so
passion this is what a lot of uh people
would say
you know what the internet's so powerful
just follow your passion
like we're living in the era where you
can turn your passion into profit true
like you know what what are you
passionate about that's what you should
do
now i agree kind of but i actually
sometimes think follow your passion is
bad advice
because passion alone is not enough but
here's the questions on this
like what do you love like what do you
really love
and what you might do is if you're
drawing this exercise we're gonna draw
three circles here
you might brainstorm because if you have
no idea where to start
you might be like well i love video
games i love music
i love sports i love food i'm really
passionate about fishing i'm really
passionate about hunting
i'm really passionate about politics
like it's actually good to cluster out
a lot of things that you're potentially
passionate about because we can find an
intersection
this might take you in a different
direction than you thought but what are
you
passionate about what do you love
here's another question for you what do
you research
like for you my wife and i if we go to
the bookstore we go to different
sections
you know i go to the sci-fi section and
i see like different the latest sci-fi
books out or whatever because i love
sci-fi
i go to the self-help section that's my
section like business self-help
you know i'm looking at whatever and i
not only do i have i own over 2 000
books right
but i get more like i'm constantly
buying books and investing in books
uh but she's like going to history books
she's going to like stick her books and
cut out books and decor you know
decorating books
so she researches like what do you geek
out online and research all night long
you know for me lenses last night i'm
studying lenses
i'm looking at different lenses i could
take uh so for when my wife and i go on
hikes
um i will read about cameras i'll read
about the sensors on them
the ibis i'll read about the latest
cameras coming out canon r5 might be
dropping in like four days i
i'm losing my mind i'm literally like up
in bed after getting ready for this
challenge just
geeking out about cameras okay so so
what do you research
what do you love um what are you
passionate about
but that is not enough
okay okay so i want you to draw another
circle now
and and i want you to overlap the circle
and here's what you're gonna write in
this circle okay you're gonna write
proficiency proficiency
i had to write it down so i know how to
spell it you might have to look that one
up proficiency proficiency
what does that one mean what are you
good at
okay what are you good at so
a couple questions on this is like what
problem do you solve or also what do you
have results in what do you have results
in
so the problem with passion let me tell
you one of mine
i am passionate about uh
i'm passionate about music love music
love singing love rap
but but as far as like real proficiency
i don't have it i remember when i was
younger in church
i thought that like hillsong joel
houston which is like a praise and
worship man
was the coolest and i had an acoustic
guitar and i was taking guitar lessons
and i was like
dude that's what i want to be when i
grow up man i want to be a singer i want
to like have the hair get the tats
get the little booty shoes skinny jeans
and i want to just go for it man you
know i want to really
and come on just just be able to sing
you know i grew up in seattle come on
kurt cobain nirvana you know
grunge but what i discovered
was that was not my proficiency you know
i could marginally improve in a certain
area but that was not
my proficiency if you're super
passionate about something on your list
you might cross out the things that
you just aren't proficient at now i'm
not saying you have to be the best in
the world at
it i'm not saying but when i think about
proficiency
here's a couple questions for you again
what problem do you solve
maybe a friend comes to you and says hey
can you help me with this
so heather is going to be teaching a
couple sessions
in this challenge she's got a homeschool
channel and so when you look at
how well-behaved her kids are and the
fact that her and her husband isaiah
had this incredible family and that she
can homeschool and like
build business and do all this stuff
people ask her
like how do you homeschool like my
friend benji
and judy were asking her about how to
homeschool because they were thinking
about doing it and then the pandemic and
the lockdown happen
so they're getting advice from her
because they look at her and even if she
didn't see
and here's what i need to speak life
into some of you some of you
you're too hard on yourself and you're
blind to your own proficiency because of
just negative self-talk
like no you're good at stuff it's the
stuff that like
you don't even know that you know but
what would your friends come and ask you
like hey can you help me with this
because i see that you're like really
good at investing like you're good at
managing your money like how are you so
disciplined all i do is spend all
my whole paycheck every time but not
only do you discipline it but like you
know where to put it
or like dude you're like really good at
fixing
cars man like you just know how to like
you could change the brake calipers
throw on the header man you can just you
freaking could
put the winch on the jeep and whatever
clearly skills
you're good at building stuff like can
you help me
like what would people ask you for see i
didn't even realize until i started
realizing uh
mid like 2014 i kind of was doing think
media
but then i realized people i wanted to
kind of be a leader and i was a pastor
at a church at the time
as a director of communications i
thought people be asking me questions
about marriage because i was like i'm a
pastor i can't i help you
and i thought maybe they'd ask me about
like faith and like life
and actually nobody was asking me
questions about any of those stuff right
i was like but i like i spoke a couple
times at the church
but i was getting hit up on facebook
messenger people like sean
what camera should i buy should i buy
what how do i set up a camera for live
streaming my church
and then eventually i was like oh i was
like kind of already doing it but i
didn't have confidence yet
oh like that's what people are asking me
maybe i should lean in on
the thing that people see a proficiency
that i maybe don't even see myself
what are you proficient at what are you
proficient at
what and then what problem do you solve
because here's a real key
you have to lean in for this
you have to understand that your youtube
channel solves a problem if you don't
understand the problem that you solve
you will always struggle like
even your tagline could be messed up
like
in a way we help people build their
influence with video that's actually
not a problem video actually solves the
problem and building your influence with
video solves the problem of as a
business owner you need more customers
as an influencer you need followers it's
usually we solve the problem of
not being known or of obscurity you
gotta know
my friend jp sears he's coming on video
influencers soon he's just hit a million
subscribers
spiritual jp ultra spiritual and him and
benji
uh i've been friends for years on our
channel over there he solves a problem
of humor but he also solves the problem
of like helping people
get set free from a lot of inner
mindsets and stuff when you go deeper in
his
brand so he's got these comedy videos
but he knows like
what he solves whether that's boredom
whether that's
escapism so proficiency inside of that
is knowing what problem you solve
and you help people solve problems
heather holmes how do i how do i start
homeschool
school homeschool versus public school i
got a problem i'm not sure how to go
forward in this
so it's at the intersection of your
passion your proficiency but that
my friends is not enough hit the like
button if you're getting value out of
this so far
there is a third circle
okay and this is what it's going to look
like
okay and this third circle
you got to write in there profit
profit profit
now profit is the business side of
things
you got to know and here's some
questions
what would someone buy from you
okay now we're going to talk more about
affiliate marketing
you know i've never made a camera right
i've never
designed a camera but but even affiliate
marketing when you've got
you know i'm passionate about video
cameras solving that problem
proficient at it because i've been doing
videos since 2003 self-taught
just learning online and whatnot but
doing it for a long time
what here's here's a myth buster you go
i haven't been doing it for that long
look you just need to be one step ahead
of the people you're gonna help
for real like if you've been doing real
estate for a year and someone's just
starting real estate
if they went to starbucks and sat you
down they're like bro can you just help
my my first year go better
like tell me everything you learn in
your first year you're like i made i
made these five mistakes
these are the three things i did right
and just
helping someone that's one step behind
you that's the power of the internet and
the power of serving people online
you just got to be one step ahead of the
person
that's behind you so even in 2010 nobody
knighted me and said sean
you now can talk about cameras you are
an authority
in cameras i appoint you anoint you and
i'm sending you forth
to go review camera i was just like
i i took a loan out to start my business
clear vision media which is a freelance
business in 2009
i got 10 grand i wasted about four grand
i just stuff i didn't use stuff that was
sitting around
i got some stuff that was good because i
did a lot of research so i started
making videos about it and i was like
here's what i wish i knew
here's why i got this here's what i
learned about this between this
i've done five hours of research 15 20
hours of research
and when you concern when you can uh
condense down
20 hours of research into a five-minute
video do you know how valuable that is
for people
you're just shortening their learning
curve you're just sharing their answers
you're just helping them go further
faster
so that might be your level of
proficiency but then you got to figure
out
how can i profit what are the best ways
to profit
okay so what would someone buy from you
and maybe you don't know yet but you
should brainstorm like maybe someday
they might buy
the tools for the fitness that i teach
they might buy training or an online
course for me they might buy
uh supplements or they might buy you
know
software or they might buy
tickets to something or an event so you
got to identify
your profit so what makes you money the
other thing here is what business do you
want to be in i'm going to keep pushing
you that even if you're
you're like i'm just a content creator
no you're a business-minded content
creator like jay-z
said i'm not a businessman i'm a
business comma man
i'm a business you're a business type in
the comments
i'm a business i know that'll kind of
rub some of you the wrong way
you're like oh i don't really want it's
not business it's just about like
adding good into the world you know it's
just about like serving i get that
but if you don't have this you're not
going to be serving anybody six months
or a year from now
like if you don't get this right you
need money for the mission
you need to fund the impact that you
want to make
this session's about how to make high
profit and high impact there ain't no
impact without income
or there's impact for like a few minutes
until you can't pay your bills anymore
can't feed your family can't keep the
lights on i'm not saying it's about
profit
profit just is what sustains the mission
you need money for the mission
i'm not a businessman i'm a business
man right i'm not a business woman i'm a
business
woman what so uh this is the
intersection now
that you want to uh
find your niche so you've brainstormed
here's some of my passions
but here's also where my greatest
strengths are and here's the ones that
could be
check this out the most profitable so if
you had two different
directions i would actually ask which
one
is going to produce more profit and i
would pick that one because
when you can create freedom and leverage
and start working from home
and have life on your own terms business
on your own terms
did you know there's some impact things
that i want to do in my life that are
still on hold because i'm getting my
business automated we're scaling up a
team
so there's books i want to write but i'm
not writing them yet because
i'm focusing on profit so that we can
sustain a whole mission
there's you know courses and things i
want to create that are not even related
to youtube that are related to like
faith and other things
but i realized that even as a biblical
example
paul created tents the apostle paul he
created tents
to fund his ministry so he had like this
practical side
of paying the bills and then he had this
vision for what his ultimate mission and
life and impact was
but when you can find the intersection
between your passion proficiency and
profit
that is where the magic happens now
there's a couple pitfalls here okay
first of all if you are passionate
and proficient then
you but there isn't profit
okay you have a hobby
like i'm really good at underwater
basket weaving now i don't want to hate
on under
water basket weaving but we're going to
talk about keyword research
and like how many people are interested
in that and actually that is a
great niche to pick but only about 7 000
people a month search for it
like the market is not very big for you
business owners and entrepreneurs it's
your tam your total addressable market
like you might i love this but like
if it's like a thing of the past it's
like some super niche
collectible of some old super niche show
that nobody watches
like there just might not be a big
enough market there
well then you can do it you just might
not make high
profit from that that's what this
challenge is about high impact and high
profit
so if you have passion and proficiency
but there's not profit connected then
you have a hobby
now if you're passionate about it
okay and it's very profitable you're
like no there's people that are killing
it in this particular niche
but you haven't developed the skills
and the proficiency for it again this is
me saying
is there profit high profit
potential in nba basketball
yeah you can get some good contracts
multi-million dollar contracts amazing
okay
am i passionate about nba basketball yes
awesome but do you have proficiency for
the nba no i don't
i'm gonna fail if i go in the nba if i
was
do i want to be the next worship leader
hillsong united
i i'm passionate they do with
songwriting credits and everything else
like
they they make a living off of their
dream but i don't got the proficiency
for it then i take that path
that is a losing scenario for my youtube
channel
okay so do you see this now draw this
out
if you just have passion and proficiency
it's just a hobby without profit if you
just have passion and profit like it's a
good niche
you love it but like nobody asks you
about it remember
my little time in being a pastor i don't
know maybe my marriage wasn't very good
at the time
but like nobody was asking me like how
do i have a stronger marriage
so maybe it was just kind of reverse
engineering that
whether i was blind to it and i don't
want to talk you out of anything but
there's something about a wake-up call
to find your sweet spot your thing i
probably shouldn't have started focus on
the family
and write a book about how to have a
strong marriage because people were not
perceiving me
with that but yet and by the way i could
not even see
if you will my own gift my own past
because i was going in every other
direction
i was focusing on my sean cannell
channel when i should have been focusing
on think media
i didn't have as much clarity as i have
today y'all i wandered in the desert i
wish i had the youtube influence
challenge
like you have right here but now here's
the last one
you might go okay i'm actually good at
this
and it actually is profitable when i
think it through i mean there's some
monetization maybe you got the youtube
starter kit and you saw the 51 ways to
make money
and you're like no this could be very
profitable but
you're really not that passionate about
it
the pitfall you can fall in here is
boredom it's boredom okay
so now
you can do this for a while and i
actually think that this is
if you catch a vision and you realize
that
what people ask you about what you
research
what you're good at and what can be
profitable
maybe funds what you want to do in your
passion in the future but here's what
i'm saying with youtube youtube takes a
lot of energy
it you pour your heart into it and so if
you're thinking about remember start
with the end in mind if you're thinking
about what you want to build
and you're thinking about a way this is
the dream
if i could do something and profit at a
high level
from something that i've got some
competency out i'm not the best in the
world you don't have to be
but i'm a step ahead and i write all the
books on it look
i remember i talked to heather who again
she
didn't have full-on confidence to start
her homeschool channel
just like all of us it's terrifying to
start youtube
it's terrifying to put yourself out
there people are gonna say it's impostor
syndrome
people are gonna say who do you think
you are sarah from high school is gonna
be like oh so you're posting videos now
huh like we go and whether sarah even
knows
like sarah's not even paying attention
but we're like making up what sarah is
saying
and i hate sarah she is so i'm just
kidding like who's sarah
uh you know and and and we make up all
these scripts but like
i was like heather how many books on
homeschool have you read
she's like all of them you know what i
mean she's like i've read like all of
them i've read like 14 books
so i'm like are you kidding me like
you've already
think about what you researched think
about what you've poured into and you
study
if you're like no i know all the things
in that ps4 game or that pc
game i'm obsessed like when you watch
someone else
when you sit there and you watch someone
else on youtube and you're like wasn't
even good information
like what the heck like someone less
talented than you
with less proficiency and even less
passion
just started taking action and you're
sitting on the sidelines because you
haven't pressed record because you're
overthinking it
the dream is if you can find the
intersection of this
when you list out your passions but you
think about industries and
niches that are the most profitable and
you think about something that you know
about
and you go in that intersection my
friends that is your sweet spot
that is your what you call in business
your usp your unique selling proposition
that little green bullseye in the middle
there
that's what you want to hit let me know
if you're getting value out of this hit
the like button
and this is where you want to niche down
as it pertains to youtube to be clear
we're going to talk more about specific
ways to make money on youtube
but for being a purpose-driven
entrepreneur that's our mission
that's our culture think media think
marketing
we want to help purpose-driven people
that means
i dare i say i think your purpose is in
the center of here
because it's something that god has
woven into your dna that you're truly
passionate about
it's something that you just have a
natural proficiency for heather doesn't
have a degree in homeschool
i don't have i didn't go to film school
right
but i have a just a creative eye and
i've worked it
i was i picked up cameras and i loved
them i looked back
i feel my brother phil jr's wedding and
it was weird i was like doing like it
was bad but i was like spinning it and
my mom was like man maybe maybe he like
he gravitates towards cameras but i
didn't even see it for years it was like
chipping away
trying to find my gift my talent my
passion but then i started to learn
about profit and so the vision of this
challenge
is how do you build a high impact
and high profit channel it's the fact
that you don't have to have
massive impact massive change lives
making a massive difference in the world
disconnected
making height from high profit you can
have both
but it's by doing the hard work of
finding this
bullseye of working through those
uh steps and so as we get ready for some
q a and i'm excited to get heather
on some feedback because she's one of
the uh most brilliant people as it
pertains to clarifying your niche and
getting breakthroughs
zig ziglar said it this way don't become
a wandering general
generality be a meaningful specific
if there was a quote that was said way
before youtube started that is relevant
to youtube
i think this is one of the most powerful
quotes a lot of wandering generalities
on youtube what's your channel about
well it's kind of about like
inspiring people okay well it's a
good start sounds pretty general
think about all these examples i didn't
just show you people who started it's
not too late to start but
that didn't just start in the last year
or two but they started
like with something specific they really
amplified their difference
you don't need to be somebody else you
don't need to compete with anybody else
you're competing with yourself and you
need to be u
times two you need to amplify your
difference
remember one of the ways to do that is
to amplify your why
not just what you do but also how you do
it because you do it differently than
anybody else
but also why you do it and when you
start to amplify your values people go
oh yeah
that's the you want to actually have
people stereotype you believe it or not
i mean of course not in a negative way
but you want to be known like i i hope
people know me as like oh sean like
that's like
the faith-driven guy like that's the guy
who's like really passionate about like
his faith man he's really passionate
about family
he's pretty bold in his beliefs like
that's the guy who's just i don't see
him like
flexing with don p and being like what
up you know
and whatever like i see i see his values
even though there's a whole bunch of
people that also do what i do they do
what i do
even similarly maybe how i do it but i
just come from a different place
that's just my difference right and that
what's your difference what's your why
and how does it connect to
your belief system you want to be a
meaningful specific
and this goes to why you want to niche
down you got to start small to get big
to win on youtube
and so as we recap here it's not too
late to start youtube we define that
high impact and high profit is found at
the center of the three ps
you want to find the best way for you to
make money it's at the center of that
well sean there's still some cloudiness
yeah we're gonna peel back the layers of
the onion
but that's what i want you thinking
through and you gotta niche
down you wanna really niche down dr i
health plants and lucia
you know the expert plumber when you
find a niche
like let me even summarize with this
it's interesting because you've actually
had a chance
to hear about if you will some of my
beliefs you've been able to hear about
the things that i'm passionate about
like leadership and family
making a difference in the world but i
have a feeling
we met because of niching down in
youtube
i'm not teaching linkedin i'm not
teaching instagram i'm actually
so not even just social media but a
niche within a niche maybe you were
searching for what's the best camera
i learned that your gift will make a way
for you that when you start small with
something specific
cameras that it can lead
to meeting people even thousands of
people in this challenge
the same is true for you and i think you
might have a mission a purpose
you've got something you really want to
accomplish but maybe there's just
something specific and what you thought
was going to be your channel
was going to be out you thought like oh
wow if i actually just help people
with tai chi if i actually just help
people
balance their checkbook then i actually
might be able to connect people because
here's what i really the difference i
really want to make in the world
and it might be layers it might take you
a while to get there
clarity is a process and it's a
commitment in this first session we said
you got to stay committed
in the first session we got you got to
commit to go all in
you have to commit okay sean you drew a
cool picture
so by tomorrow in the afternoon should i
have crystal clarity i hope you do
but my friends this took me months and
it took me being connected to a powerful
community it took me being able to
bounce my ideas off other people
it took me continuing to have
conversations with my wife
it took me having conversations with
myself it took me having conversations
with god
it took me uh just like
going through the process and the
process of the process but today
our brand is so clear and our movement
is so powerful
you've seen the results but you got to
be willing to commit to do
the work and go all in and remember
commitment is the foundation of all
great accomplishments
i want you to commit to this challenge i
want you to commit to your future
i want you to commit to going all in on
youtube and commit to doing the work i'm
not saying this is easy but i'm saying
it's worth it
you saw all the opportunities that are
happening with youtube those aren't
becoming less they're just becoming more
youtube continues to grow but commitment
my friends
is the foundation of great
accomplishments
omg i hope you took notes during that
session
sean was bringing the fire as he broke
down
profit proficiency and passion and i
hope after this episode
that you go and take action too we love
seeing
all of you think action takers over on
social media so make sure to tag us
at sean cannell and at miss heather
taurus and use our hashtag
think marketing so we can follow along
on your journey too
and if you have not checked out our free
one hour
youtube masterclass i highly encourage
you to do that
next go to thinkmasterclass.com to
register for that today
thank you so much for being a part of
the think media community and we
encourage you to share this episode with
a friend
we would also love if you would rate and
review this podcast over on
itunes and if you're watching on youtube
leave a comment
sharing your aha moment from today's
episode well now it's time to take
action
and i can't wait to see you in a future
episode
you